Remember me.
Yeah.
I am the fallen soldier,
sailor, airman, and marine.
I am the one that held the line.
Sometimes I volunteered.
Sometimes I went because I was told to go,
but when the nation called,
I answered
in order to serve,
I left behind the family,
friends and freedom that
so many take for granted.
Over time I use different weapons.
Yeah,
a sword, a musket, a bayonet,
a rifle or a machine gun.
Often I marched into battle on foot,
countless miles across all continents.
I had little water and even less food,
but it did not matter.
We had a job to do.
Other times I wrote a battle
on horseback or in wagons,
sometimes on trains later in
tanks or jeeps or Humvees.
In early wars, my ships were made
of wood and powered by the wind.
Later they were made of steel and
powered by diesel fuel or the atom.
I even took to the air and
mastered the sky in planes,
helicopters and jets.
The machines of war evolved
and changed with the Times.
Yeah,
but remember that it was always me,
the warrior that had to
fight our nation's enemies.
I fought at Lexington and
Concord as our nation was born,
I crossed the Delaware on Christmas
day in 1776 freedom was on our side.
Yeah,
I defended the Chattahoochee river in
the war of 1812 I would stand again
in the civil war.
I fought with my brothers and against
my brothers at Gettysburg and Shiloh and
bull run.
I learned that we must never again divide
in world war one. I marched on the
Marne and held the line at Bellwood,
the war to end all wars.
They called it.
I just called it hell
in World War I fought everywhere from
the beaches of Normandy and the battle of
the bulge to the sands of Whoa
Jima and the hell of Guadalcanal.
I stood against
and kept darkness from
consuming the world.
In Korea. I landed at Inchon and
broke out of the chosen reservoir.
They called it the forgotten war,
but I never forgot.
In Vietnam,
I went had I fought
in the Mekong Delta and I drank
and case on and Hamburger Hill.
Some say my country wavered,
but I did not waver
ever
in the recent past. I fought
in Grenada, Panama, Somalia,
and other desperate
places around the globe.
Then finally,
I have fought in Iraq and Afghanistan
in Baghdad and Fallujah and Ramadi.
Yeah,
in Coonara and Helmand and Kandahar
as technology advanced,
I use night vision goggles and global
positioning systems and drones and lasers
and thermal optics,
but it was still me or human
being that did the work.
Yeah.
It was me that patrolled up the mountains
or across the desert or through the
streets. It was me that suffered in
the merciless heat and the bitter cold.
It was me that went out night after night
to confront our nation's enemies and
confront evil face to face.
It was me.
Remember me?
I was a warrior,
but also remember
that I was not only a warrior,
I was not just a soldier,
sailor, airman, or marine.
Remember also
that I was a son,
a brother,
a father.
I was a daughter. A
sister. A mother, yeah.
How was a person
like you? A real person with
hopes and dreams for the future?
I wanted to have children.
I wanted to watch my children grow up.
I wanted to see my son's score a
touchdown or shoot the winning basket.
I want it to walk my
daughter down the aisle.
I wanted to kiss my wife again.
I wanted to grow old with her and be there
to hold her hand when life grew hard.
When I told her I would be with
her until the end, I meant it
when I told my children,
I would always be there for them.
I meant it.
Yeah,
but I gave all that away.
Yeah.
All of it.
On that distant battlefield,
on some God forsaken patch of dirt
amongst the fear and the fire and the
bullets,
or in the sky above enemy
territory filled with fatal flack
or in the unforgiving.
See where we fought against the enemy
and against the depths of the abyss
there
in those awful places,
I held the line,
I did not waver and I did not hesitate.
Aye,
the soldier, sailor, airman or marine.
I stood my ground and sacrificed my life,
my future, my hopes, my
dreams. I sacrificed everything
for you
this memorial day.
Remember me?
Yeah,
the fallen warrior,
Ben,
remember me? Not For
my sake, but for years.
Remember what I sacrificed.
So you can truly appreciate the
incredible treasures you have.
Life,
liberty,
the pursuit of happiness.
Do you have the joys of life,
the joys that I gave up?
Yeah.
So that you can relish in them.
Cool breeze in the air,
the gentle spring grass on your bare feet,
the warm summer sun on your face.
Family,
friends
that freedom.
Never forget where it all came from.
It came from sacrifice,
the supreme sacrifice.
Don't waste it.
Don't waste any of your
time on this earth.
Live a life that honors the
sacrifice of our fallen heroes.
Remember them always
and make every day
memorial day.